well isn't that odd okay we watched the
medical dramas we played the games but
now it's time to take a look at one of
the most successful animated series of
all time the simpsons
[Music]
why are they shocking everybody even in
the cartoons they take it from the
medical dramas and they're shocking
everybody chest compressions if they're
hard to stop and they're not breathing
and my man's going more
more well we can't fix his heart but we
can tell you exactly how damaged it is
what an age we live in it's classic in
medicine where we don't have all the
solutions and people right away start
saying oh medicine sucks how come we
don't have this maybe you're just a
doctor that doesn't know what the cure
to this problem is no the human body is
very complex and while we know a lot
about it there's still a lot more left
to learn homer this is a new body fat
analysis test i start your jiggling and
measure how long it takes to stop
caliper test weightless pool tests for
body fat percentage punch in the gut
best in the simpsons mr simpson i'm
afraid you have a crayon lodged in your
brain there's a crayon in my brain
but i've had thousands of head x-rays
how come no one ever noticed it before
oh i can answer that you see whenever i
pick up an x-ray i always hold it like
this
my thumb must have covered up the crayon
when you look at an x-ray you have to
look at many things including the issue
at hand so a person has shortness of
breath you want to look at the lungs you
also want to look at the surrounding
structures because the last thing you
want to do is look at an x-ray to see if
the patient has a pneumonia and miss the
cancer that's growing in their humerus
or on their rib or on their clavicle
this place seems even nicer than the
mayo clinic
male clinic eh
should we slice them diagonally or just
cut off the crust
why is it called the mayo clinic it's
gotta be because there was a doctor that
started it with the last name mayo it
has nothing to do with mayonnaise
founders charles and william mayo look
at that
it's like i went to medical school and
all this whole morning has been
wonderful
too wonderful
[Music]
there's actually a really adorable video
of like a doctor who does this whole
like show for kids with the needle to
get them excited about it and then like
fake injects themselves and then injects
the child and then they don't even feel
the pain because there's so much going
on for kids who are able to reason
somewhat i try and talk to them as if
they're adults i bargain with them and i
say i'm gonna give you you know this
really cool pillow
and they're like why do we want a pillow
that looks like you and i'm like true
and i get them uh something else that is
furry and cute and soft like bear or i
give them stickers of their favorite
shows and they're like oh that's awesome
what are we doing today i'm like well
today you're gonna get a vaccine a shot
here's why blah blah blah they're like
okay that sounds fair you gave me a
sticker and a weird pillow so you must
be nice i give them a quick shot i'm
very gentle we're very good with it my
nurses are amazing and then they leave
happy himbert money making organization
is that what hmo stands for this whole
time i can provide every medical service
you'll ever need under one roof rubble
palm full of this medicated salve into
your scalp every half an hour keep him
away from open flames and pregnant women
ah they should help those fallen arches
enjoy
hmm
throat looks a little red i better spray
it
oh my god this is my favorite skit ever
and i think it has less to do with hmos
but in general the fact that people in
our society have grown up with this
theory inside their head that they need
to see a specialist in order to stay
healthy and it's so not true because
specialists oftentimes deal with really
complex cases they treat things a little
bit more aggressively than your family
medicine or your primary care doctor
would please don't think you need to see
a specialist for everything because a
that will happen b many things will go
away on their own and you don't need to
spend a whole ton of money to see a
specialist in order for that to happen
and c your primary care doctor is well
versed in solving all these problems and
not only are we well versed in solving
them we know you best because we have an
existing relationship now doctor i want
you to test me for everything every
disease on this chart
fine we'll just start by drawing some
blood
well isn't that odd okay
i'm gonna hit simpsons hard with the
medical inaccuracies we do not stab
patients with a syringe and have it come
out the other side of their arm and be
like oh i guess it's not working we do
not just check for a bunch of diseases
when you come in for a checkup part of
that is figuring out what diseases we
can actually screen for there are some
like cancers what diseases we can
prevent we could also look at what risks
you face so get this a patient comes in
doesn't have liver disease but they talk
to me honestly we have a good
conversation it finds out they're
drinking a bottle and a half of vodka a
day it's a lot but some people do do
this we have a conversation about hey
what can we do to prevent them from
drinking and driving what we can do for
them uh preventing themselves causing
harm in other ways themselves when they
are inebriated how can we get them to
cut down the amount that they're
drinking so they can stay healthier
longer look at how much i've affected
their lifespan the progression of
disease simply by having a good
conversation that's what you should
expect from a doctor when you go in for
a physical if you get anything less than
that please look for a second opinion mr
burns i'm afraid you are the sickest man
in the united states you have everything
you mean i have pneumonia yes juvenile
diabetes yes hysterical pregnancy uh a
little bit yes you also have several
diseases that have just been discovered
first of all how does he have juvenile
diabetes he's not of juvenile age
this sounds like bad news well you'd
think so but all of your diseases are in
perfect balance here's the door to your
body you see and these are oversized
novelty germs uh that's influenza that's
bronchitis and this cute little
cuttlebug is pancreatic cancer
here's what happens when they all try to
get through the door at once
move it shout ahead we call it three
stooges syndrome
no if you have a lot of diseases it's
not better than having less diseases
also if you're a good doctor and a lot
of tests come up positive you need to
start looking for a cause that perhaps
ties in all of these diseases together i
don't just say hey you got a bunch of
diseases deuces
there's a crazy man with a scalpel in er
he's demanding to see a quack
hi everybody now tell dr nick where is
the trouble i met g i got ants in my
pants i'm discombobulated give me a call
motif slow down sir you're going to give
yourself skin failure what is skin fail
i think skin failure is just when your
skin just gives up and starts slothing
off stephen johnson syndrome
insert the retractor and crank it until
the ribs swing open like a rusty
drawbridge no
blood silly but truth to it we do watch
videos on procedures all the time and
that's a good thing you want your doctor
up to date and seeing the procedure
before they do it even if they've done
it multiple times that little refresher
goes a long long way and you know where
we do a lot of it
youtube your doctor watches youtube
before they perform surgeries on you
that's the truth these gloves came free
with my toilet brush usually you have
someone help you with the gloves have
the package open because remember the
inside of the package is sterile but the
outside is not so there's a specific way
you actually have to put the gloves on
to make sure that you're keeping sterile
what the hell is that that's something
you don't want to hear from your surgeon
that and oops i know i'm supposed to cut
something but what and where the mask is
not part of the sterile field so if you
make contact with your mask right away
you have to leave change gloves re-scrub
in and do the whole process all over
again so my man is not sterile no more
dr nick riviera remember me well if it
is my old friend mr mccraeg with a leg
for an arm and a non-far leg the only
question i have after watching that is
what is that doctor's specialty dr nick
what do you do simpsons all in all does
a great job of teaching you medicine
albeit satirically but as you've seen
with the onion episodes in the past i
don't mind a little satire and speaking
of the onion check out my onion review
here and my saturday night live medical
skit reviews which one are you cooking
which one are you enjoying and as always
stay happy and healthy
[Music]